so connor what was the first figure that
you bought then all right well i spent a
lot of money here so yeah
do the challenges first perfect
bloody hell that's a long receipt you
bet it is so i had one challenge which
was to buy something from a movie that
joey buy something from an anime that
joey has watched in 2021 yeah okay
which is a little easier than what you
should buy one you saw recently yeah
yeah it's not like i've seen zero this
year unbelievably i know luckily this
wasn't too difficult as last minute
before we had to leave the store i
remembered that joey in length had
spoken about watching the evangelion
movie yeah so i bought i just bought
nava oh nice oh nice i know you're what
you're gonna say you're gonna be like oh
it's not the right type from the right
because i know it has the movie on it
but it isn't it isn't though no it isn't
it isn't
that's not that's not even close you had
so many ava options
actually that's you know what it is
that's not even like canon evangelion
what's even going this is evangelion in
train form it's even going what the [ __ ]
actually yeah yeah it's not even an eva
it's an ava collab with shinkanyong oh
it's ava which [ __ ] did you buy it you
had so many choice of ava
have you bought a [ __ ] ava shinkansen
if it's a jojo collab with a with
t-shirt it's still jojo you know what i
mean
it's still evangelion what are you all
about
connor i should get the point yeah
that's uh that's proper there you go you
also bought an evangelion gun yeah so
you both lose a point no no yes oh okay
we don't we do yeah yeah
i got him i got a point and then lost it
yeah no you didn't even get a point you
lost it no i get it
now you don't even that is not you look
if we're not going to count my recent
anime well we're not counting it's the
ava bro that's the
you literally could have picked so many
evangelion figures you picked the one
that's a [ __ ] train either
none of uh either i get no point yeah
and gant gets a point yeah or gaunt
loses a point and i get no point
no wait what no no if this is if no no
no you both lose a point so you're not
gonna i
point and god loses one yeah so he
doesn't get a point and he also loses a
point
i'm happy i'm content with making god
lose a point
i will give you the point if you can if
you can say that i get the point for the
[ __ ] uh humans of the either one no
no no because it's the exact same i only
gave you the half a point for these
no because the exact same vein no it's
not yes it is
i'm sorry i don't remember watching shin
cutty on in 2021 it wasn't about
watching shin kalyan it's about getting
old
i don't remember that being in 4.0 i'm
sorry evangelion figure series it
literally says it on the [ __ ] box
i need to know connor why did you choose
that figure there were so many ava
figures there because all of them look
so boring what about the bna one that
you said you were gonna buy
yeah i found out that because we
literally did a video this year on the
netflix yeah then i went to my calendar
and we actually filmed that in like
december
oh really so god damn so gant loses one
point and i get nothing cause i lost the
point i gained no we we both know you
both lose the point both lose the point
yeah and then i get the point for you
you don't get the point
i only lose the point if i get the point
because you'd have to admit that it's an
either for me to lose the point to begin
with
so what i'm saying is right if you would
oh that means it's either you'd lose no
points or you lose two points no it's
either i lose no points or god gets a
point
no i don't get any points he doesn't get
any points i just don't lose a point
yeah so then i get a point you know what
you're losing the point if you if you
admit that you lose a point you're
admitting this isn't evangelion i'm
going crazy
this isn't this isn't
okay you know what you know what i'd
rather i'd rather not admit that that's
an evangelion then admit that we got the
same figure yeah so
i'll tell you what yeah so doesn't lose
any points and you don't lose any points
how's that we're we're exactly where we
[ __ ] start so both of you have zero
this isn't even gallium it literally
says it on the box i did not watch
evangelion with a [ __ ] shinkansen
reboot i did i don't know what you were
watching jerry i watched the english dub
where they had this in it
look look look they're they're we
literally no way
do you remember that scene in 4.0 when
they bust out the evangelion concept
look we literally in ava 3.0 plus one
got introduced to evangelion infinity
but even in the infinite possibilities i
don't think that was one of them this is
one of the infinite possibilities okay
i don't think even infinity can uh take
account of whatever the [ __ ] that is of
course i don't think so
is that why you're acting so smug joey
no i'm acting so smug because i know
that's not evangelion that clearly says
on the side of the back i can read it's
evangelion what the [ __ ] is this that's
the at field
ah from evangelion right you know what
bringing bringing bringing the attention
away from this clown for a moment this
is actually oh my god holy [ __ ]
why are you buying figures they don't
fit in the [ __ ] shelf that's so good
none of these figures fit in the shelf
guard
i went with my heart okay one of them i
quitted with my heart this just looks
like a cool [ __ ] figure look at this
where are we going to put this guy i'm
back at the toilet
there's just going to be a there's just
going to be a toilet shrine with all the
cool figures
i'm trying to be the [ __ ] and
actually think about our set for a
moment
yeah see this one fits perfectly on the
set that's not going on the same yeah
look out look how tight it is
it fits perfectly on this get
demonetized every [ __ ] episode what
do you mean she's wearing clothes yeah
in the meantime let me show you oh wait
oh you got a pics
what my name is
is that to do with a challenge no he
just wanted it i just want a pathfinder
he's my main